Así es el día de hoy la jefa de gobierno
Claudia sheinbaum y el el líder de la
mayoría morenista en el senado Ricardo
Monreal anunciaron que será este viernes
16 de junio cuando se separen de sus
cargos en el caso de Claudio sheinbaum
dijo que el jueves por la tarde tendrá
un encuentro con ciudadanos para
exponerle los avances de su gobierno y
plantear lo que viene para el futuro
dijo que ella está confiada De que al
ser la única mujer en la encuesta que se
aplicará Y ser también quien proviene de
el mundo científico pero a la vez
también de la lucha política tiene
amplias posibilidades el senador Ricardo
Monreal dijo que presentará su solicitud
de licencia a la mesa directiva de la
cámara alta hablando de posibilidades
bueno en la propia Claudia sheinbaum
dijo que en la mayoría de las encuestas
que se han aplicado hasta el momento en
distintos medios distintas casas
encuestadoras ella es quien está en la
cabeza y confía en continuar
en ese nivel en cuanto al senador
Monreal Bueno pues los distintos
ejercicios demoscópicos lo ubican en un
cuarto lugar sin embargo él tiene
confianza en que puede remontar una vez
ya comenzando Esta carrera interna por
la por la candidatura ahora otro de Los
favoritos es Marcelo ebrard quien hoy
oficializó su dimisión en el cargo de
secretario de relaciones exteriores Qué
se sabe sobre quién asumirá ese cargo
Así es Marcelo ebrard este mediodía
presentó al presidente López Obrador su
renuncia con carácter de definitiva dijo
que fue una charla que tuvo con el
presidente muy cordial recordaron viejos
tiempos y de lleno ya se dedica desde el
día de hoy a hacer la campaña la
precampaña para conseguir esta
postulación la ley del servicio exterior
indica que es la subsecretaria de
relaciones exteriores Carmen Moreno
toscano quien debe asumir el despacho
digamos de la cancillería sin embargo el
presidente López Obrador ha dado a
conocer que este martes se reunirá con
todo su gabinete para pedirles que
expresen de una vez quién piensa
continuar y quién desea contender por
algún cargo para que él pueda ya definir
a los relevos a los que ocuparán las
vacantes que están dejando quienes
aspiran a esta candidatura presidencial
del partido Morena ha dicho también el
secretario de gobernación que se
separará del cargo a Don n Augusto López
de manera que serán varias las vacantes
porque no nada más se van ellos sino
también se van sus equipos más cercanos
y el presidente tendrá que hacer un
reacomodo